I want to hear about it my father  doesn't have to be around this is a big  mistake this is another big mistake  especially among the conservatives of  the track cons and all this crap the  idea that a father needs to sit around  like a second mother to make a child  healthy it's a fallacy in fact I'd say  it's detrimental to the child I see all  these dudes out here they have a kid and  they basically become mother number two  why the mother keeps the Child Alive as  a father it's your job to be impactful  we need to guide we need to be a role  model you need to be a superhuman I want  you to look at their father like a  superhero that's what you should  genuinely view them as it's hard to be a  superhero of your home every day arguing  with your wife changing diapers that's  not what a man should do a man should  Rock up teach lessons be impactful and  it's more about quality as opposed to  quantity of time